نرحب بالعقيد حاتم كريم الفلاحي الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي معنا من
اسطنبول العقيد الفلاحي سحب اللواء الخامس
من قطاع غزه في اطار ما يعرف بتقليص اعداد
الجنود هناك الى اي مدى يعتبر مؤشر الى حد
ما على الدخول في مرحله جديده من هذا
العدوان نعم لا شك بان سحب اللواء الخامس
الان من المنطقه الشماليه حصرا يعني يعتبر
هو مؤشر على دخول هذه المنطقه الى المرحله
الثالثه بتقليل القطاعات المتواجده في هذه
المنطقه علما بان اللواء الخامس كان يعمل
ضمن الفرقه 162 المسؤوله عن قطاع غزه
ولواء الشمال وبالتالي هذه الفرقه تتالف
من اللواء 401 ايضا لازال موجود ولواء
نحال اللي هو لواء 933 لازال موجود ويبدو
بان القوه في هذه المنطقه لا تحتاج الى
جهد كبير بالاضافه الى لواء الشمال طبعا
فسحب هذه القوات من هذه المنطقه مؤشر واضح
على انه هناك انتقال الى المرحله الثالثه
علما بان هذا اللواء في الاصل هو اللواء
الخامس يتبع الى الفرقه 340 فرقه عيدان
التي تتبع ضمن شبكه تنظيم الجيش الصهيوني
الى قياده المنطقه الوسطى علما بان اللواء
الذي سحب قبل ايام لواء كرياتي اللواء
الرابع هو لواء مدرع ويتبع الى قياده
المنطقه الشماليه وهذا يعني بان هناك
حسابات عسكريه اخرى تدخل في مساله سحب هذه
القطعات خلال هذه الفتره لانه يمكن ان
تسحب القطعات عندما تكون هناك خسائر يمكن
ان تسحب القطعات عندما تكون هناك عمليه
اعاده تنظيم او تسحب عندما تكون هناك
مناوره بالقطاعات واستخدام هذه القطاعات
في واجب اخر اما ان يكون ضمن القاطع او
ضمن واجبات اخرى وبالتالي هناك اسباب
كثيره جدا لسحب هذه القطع خلال هذه الفتره
ولكن
التصريحات نعم في هذا الاطار الحديث عن
مشكله عميقه كما يقول وزير الدفاع الا
اسرائيلي الى اي مدى يتماهى ربما مع سحب
اللواء
الخامس نعم حقيقه الجيش الصهيوني يعاني من
اشكاليه حقيقيه في مساله ان القطعات التي
تقاتل الان في غزه يعني هذه القطعات لا
تنتمي الى المنطقه الجنوبيه فقط وانما
تنتمي تنتمي الى الى مناطق اخرى يعني
عندما نتكلم عن الفرقه 36 قاطع مسؤوليه
الفرقه 36 هي المنطقه الشماليه باتجاه
لبنان و يعني هذه المنطقه تم سحب هذه
الفرقه والمجيء بها الى المنطقه الجنوبيه
في المنطقه الوسطى هناك كثير من الالويه
يعني هذا اللواء الذي نتكلم عليه يعتبر من
الويه النخبه لدى قوات الاحتياط ولكن يتبع
الى قياده المنطقه الوسطى سحب هذه الالويه
جميعا وتكديسها في المنطقه الجنوبيه لا شك
هو يسبب اشكال كبير جدا لل الجيش الصهيوني
في مساله المناوره بالقطاعات يعني عندما
تكون هناك جبهات اخرى مفتوحه في مناطق
اخرى ستكون هناك صعوبه في مساله المناوره
بالقطاعات لمواجهت هذا هذا التصعيد سواء
كان في الشمال او سواء كان في مناطق اخرى
من اسطنبول العقيد حاتم كريم الفلاحي
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا
لك